let's shift out of politics because I
want to talk about your book okay and
and I guess the best way to do that
really is to first talk about your own
personal journey yeah you were once an
atheist you are no longer any that's
right
I'm no Christian I was once a secular
Jew it was a way to put so so born
Jewish not particularly religious so you
but raised raised in the tradition but
kind of without God you know like taught
I was bar Mitzvahed and all this stuff
and yeah but both my parents really
didn't believe in anything that does
seem to sort of be modern Jewish or at
least American Jewish thought it's not
very religious but it's cultural or
something I would say if you really want
to destroy the Jews just leave them
alone because though they'll go off on
their own but it could they'll all
assimilate yeah they you know whatever
yeah so okay so you were secular Jewish
then became an atheist around what age
well I was I would say I was an agnostic
a practicing atheist but I was most of
my life I was an agnostic there was one
short period when I became an atheist
and then realized that that made no
sense and so and that actually started
me back on the the other room so what
was the no sense part or what was the
agnostic party or you were you because
you weren't secular your family was a
Clary well III what happened was I I was
bar Mitzvahed and I felt that I didn't
want to be I felt that I didn't believe
in what I was saying and it was a an
offense to my sense of myself to stand
up in front of family and friends and
say these words that I did not believe
and I talk about in the book that I you
know I received all this guilt all this
is all these gifts for my bar mitzvah
thousands of dollars worth of them and I
put them in this leather box and first I
was thrilled you know here I was 13 I
had all this well and over the course of
about six months I it it started to turn
I started to think you know this is
ill-gotten gains I lied to get this
money and I waited till everybody went
to bed in my house and I crept outside
and I threw the books away really and
yes and that was that was meant to be
the end of my religious life I thought
who wants to feel like this it's awful
no but I didn't feel like I had to make
a decision you know my one nice thing
for you by thirteen I know I'd like to
go back
a little parting here I threw it all
away and that's principled I mean that's
how you know someone principled well you
know it didn't occur to me till many
many years later that it must have been
important to me to tell the truth about
God you know that that alone made me
realize that it was more that the
question was more important to me than I
kind of admitted to myself I just
thought well forget about so I call
myself an agnostic because I was a
practicing atheist you know but I just
thought well who knows you know what
what difference does it make to me since
it's obviously has no effect on the
world around me yeah I became an atheist
what would happen I had a tear I loved
two lives I mean I talked about this on
the book at the age of 28 I was out of
my mind and at the age of 28 I cracked
up and I went to a psychiatrist and he
cured me I mean it was from it was so
dramatic that they I always think of
this onion headline psychiatrist cures
patient on that guy you're the one guy
the one guy that's like I do understand
reality that you you know that's he's
he's the typical psychiatric patient you
know a hundred years many marries a
stepdaughter you know that
ya know right yeah but but I was cured I
went from being absolute miserable and
unable to act to being a happy really
joyful person who was you know became
successful in my career and was doing
exactly what I want a wonderful family
and all the stuff that was the point
when I felt out of personal integrity I
had to become an atheist because Freud
was an atheist and it was a kind of semi
for right also born Jewish yes yes and I
better but he was a big virulent atheist
yeah really insisted that atheism was oh
that religion was just a neurosis plus
as I began to realize through certain
spiritual experiences that there was a
spiritual side to life I took up Zen and
I had that kind of Zen experience where
everything sort of became like you know
life is an illusion and all that was
clear and I just let you know that this
is leading me to atheism and so I became
philosophically an atheist I didn't
really change emotionally because I
already was not caring about the whole
thing you know
and I start to read atheist works and
one day I read the Marquis de Sade
and the Marquis de Sade makes an
argument for atheism that is the only as
I would read these atheists I would
think that doesn't make sense that
doesn't really make sense when you
follow these atheists down the road it
really doesn't make sense they seem to
they sound like they're saying rational
stuff and then you go like wait wait
that's not working
the market is had worked all the way you
make perfect sense if there is no God
there can be no morality if there is no
morality do what nature tells you to do
what nature tells you to do is have
pleasure a pleasure of other people's
expense you know what there was in a
wife should interpret Spence and that's
what he took pleasure and I thought
that's the first atheist philosophy I've
ever heard that makes sense from A to Z
that makes sense and as a leap of faith
I thought I can't go there that's hell
to me to live taking pleasure of other
people's suffering I know that's wrong I
know it's wrong I don't care if they say
it's right I don't care if everybody
else on earth says it it's right I don't
care if everybody on earth says it's
right it's still wrong and that's the
only leap of faith I ever took that's
the only that's the only part of my
religion faith everything else is based
on that premise so okay so let me let me
try to I'm gonna push back a little bit
but try to extrapolate some of this
stuff so how if it's all based in
morality and you can't you know then
aren't there many many atheists out
there that are in that are extremely
happy people in perfectly moral
relationships that only put good out
there and all of them absolutely it has
nothing to do with so then what's the
word what am ia philosophies doesn't
make any sense
see that's most of us live with
philosophies that don't make any sense
one of the quirks of my personality
which is kind of what this book is about
is that I want what I say to be exact
you know you'll see people who all the
time who say there's no morality it's
it's your opinion versus my opinion then
they go home and they treat their
children well and they don't cheat on
their wives and you know if you question
them they might say some cynical thing
but that's not true that's not the way
they're not speaking the truth of their
lives they're not speaking the truth of
their lives if they did they would have
to start thinking well where does this
morality come from how do I know it why
do I know that it's right not to cheat
on my wife you know why do I know that
that's the right
thing that because I gave my word I
won't do it anymore you know why do I
know that my word should reflect my
actions then most people just don't
think about it they just don't think
about so they can be perfectly decent
but they're living in a world that
religion made to some degree but
wouldn't it why why does that matter I
suppose if you know you mean like at the
end of the day if I was sitting here
with someone who lived their life as
authentically and positively and as true
as you live yours but without the
philosophical jump that you took there
or this the spiritual jump I suppose
really the leap of faith that you took
ultimately you're not arguing that it
would make a difference it just makes a
difference for you I said well no wait
wait it doesn't make a difference to you
and me we can still have a beer and be
friends yeah good guy I know I can trust
you and that's great you know that's
that's wonderful so it doesn't make a
difference there it makes a difference
in the broader sphere because when
people come and argue that you should
have a safe space when people come and
argue that you should tell that be able
to tell that guy not to say what he
wants to say when people come and argue
that they should take your freedom away
you don't know why they're wrong you
don't have a philosophy that goes down
to the ground they can always out argue
you but what if he does this but what if
this happens what if they guy if the guy
if we don't force the kind of wear
seatbelts he'll he'll die and then his
mother will be sad you know you know
they can make all these surface
arguments and you don't know what you
believe and why you believe it you don't
know why the founders said you are
endowed by your creator with certain
inalienable rights once you stop
believing that then Barack Obama's in
charge of your rights you know and if
and if your philosophy doesn't work down
to the ground when these guys come along
with their arguments which are
frequently very good sounding you start
to lose the things that matter you know
you know eat anything you have in life
can't be judge until you know what it's
for you know is that a good glass or a
bad glass well if it's there to hold
water it's doing pretty good job you
know that's the thing right you can't
really know what is good for you until
you know what you're for and what your
purpose is and and so it while you're
right it you're absolutely right it
makes no difference whether a person is
a good person or a great person you know
has it you can be
a great a theist a person that I would
love you know yeah and follow and you
know elect and all these things but when
the argument comes down to take people's
freedom away if the underlying beliefs
aren't sound those arguments so why
couldn't the underlying belief be that
there's goodness in man so to speak that
it's it comes from you not necessarily
from your Creator but there's something
innate within us that would allow you to
always stand up for freedom would always
allow you stand up for liberty free
speech or all of those things that that
you would be concerned they could come
get you for right couldn't you make the
same arguments that you would make
against that without the faith part not
really I mean you you could say that
that's true and you'd be right you know
you say you say this is true right but
it doesn't make full sense because when
you say that something is morally better
than something else it means that it is
closer to an absolute moral good if
nothing is good if there's no such thing
as a good then you can't be more good
than something else right I think it was
a line right there's no good and bad
then you can't be on that line and
ultimate moral good just by logic but
just by logic is going to have certain
qualities it's going to have to be
conscious because goodness is always a
conscious choice you know or hurricane
isn't bad because it kills people you
know I thought hurricanes are because
the gays act what no no you need to
accept yeah I think you have gone beyond
my yeah my expertise but but uh you know
a lightning strike isn't bad because
kill somebody because it has no choice
so ultimate good is going to have to be
rational it's gonna have to be a
consciousness and then you start to get
to the point of God and the other thing
about that God is he's going to have to
look something like you there's going to
have to be some kind of connection
because you know what he knows you know
which direction he's in you have a
connection to him so that in me that
thing that you said is true we do have
an innate consciousness you know that
Kant said the the starry sky above and
the moral law within we do have that but
it it implies it implies a God and
implies an absolutely
so how does Christianity fit into this
for you
well Christianity fits into it in in the
following way that that if there is an
ultimate moral good which is a God and
if we know where he is then the line
about him making us in His image starts
to make perfect sense and now you have
to start to think about this you know I
always hear these thinkers and got these
are guys I love reading like Steven
Pinker I love reading history but he's
always talking about the ghost in the
machine and I keep thinking like who
believes in a ghost in a machine that's
us you know that if that's your argument
that's who you're arguing with people
who believe that there's a ghost in your
machine you know no that's not the way
it works
it's a little hyperbole I mean I think I
let on yeah you know we we know we know
that the world is not Material because
we have ideas right there's no such
thing as two plus two equals four and
yet it's true right that the words that
we speak that that idea doesn't come
into being until we speak it until we
think it you know but it's not the thing
it's not the brain waves it's not the
words it's something else but it only
exists in life when we speak it when we
think it okay that's the spirit
the flesh is language the flesh is a
language for speaking the spirit that's
what it is it's it's not like a ghost in
a machine we are we are the language of
the spirit you know that's what it is
once you start to think about it like
that you start to see like yeah it kind
of makes sense that at some point along
the line those two things would converge
that spirit and that flash and that you
would have a word that was made flesh
you would have the Word of God that was
made flesh it starts to make sense
now look I don't I don't insist that
people believe in this all I would say
is that if you start to thinking through
what happened to me what happened to me
was not so much that I thought I yes
this must be it what happened was
everything else that I believed was
explained by the Gospels what was the
age that kicked in I was close to 50 so
that was close to fit yeah so what so
when you had the awakening of the self
at 28 where he
where you were fixed yes you described
it bye-bye therapy what what caused you
to need that 22 years later that's such
a great question because I'm such a such
a stubborn ornery cos that the idea of
believing in God when I was in trouble
when I needed him when you know just I
just let well that's just a crutch you
know that's just a crutch
so it was only when I felt sane when I
could trust my own perceptions because
what one of the things we talk about all
the time is subjectivity people say oh
well you just feel that that's moral so
that's not real but I fell in love when
I was 20 and I'm still in love with the
same person so clearly something that I
perceived subjectively had an outward
truth right so before I could felt that
I could trust my subjectivity I had to
feel I was sane and it really took me
ten years from the point when I was
cured to say you know what net first of
all I became educated during that time I
read all these books and secondly I felt
like oh when I feel something when I see
something and I'm confirmed by logic
it's real when I think I love my wife
and then I see like 40 years later I'm
still crazy about her and that's real
you know I'm perceiving something she
loved the broken one and The Fixer
learning was stuck with that you know
that's yes religion that's a heroic
thing you know that's real love and so
and so that was part of it I needed to
be joyful before I could accept God
because I didn't want to take on I would
because it I didn't trust myself yeah if
if it was helping me in some way what do
you think is I know that a lot a lot of
my audience obviously is atheist and I
want to bring on more people faith
really in general it's just so happened
that a lot of people that I'm interested
in talking to happen to be atheist but
I'm thoroughly enjoying it but I know a
certain amount of people who say well
Dave's not pushing back enough on this
or that but my version of atheism would
be that it you've laid out a case that
works for you and if that leap of faith
was necessary for you I would have to be
some sort of pompous jackass to to try
to you know
convinced you a deacon is you can see
right or just to change what you think
has clearly worked for you so this is a
case where I think atheists in general
could be a little more tolerant of the
other again again cuz I don't think any
the principles that you live by are not
things that atheist wouldn't be down
with but serum from what I can get but I
don't think that their arguments make
sense and by the way and and by the way
I've I get nothing at a good convince
you I get Green Stamps in heaven I guess
we get within eight years here right
yeah but but I have to say that when I
listen to the guys who are talking about
it you know there's a great push to look
at human beings as material if you even
listen to the way people speak they say
an adrenaline rush like why don't you
see got excited you bring enough
adrenaline didn't cause you to be
excited you're excited cause your
adrenaline moves you know that's because
you are an expression of a spirit that's
the you know it's not the other way
around and therefore when people get
depressed you know they invented these
wonderful drugs that if you have a
chemical imbalance they they may fix
your imbalance now that's how they
invented yeah now they said you they
save you well if you've been you know
depressed for two weeks you should take
these drugs and my feeling is if you
haven't been depressed for two weeks
you're not paying attention right now
it's like you should take if you haven't
been depressed you should take drugs
yeah that's somebody isn't that the
human condition I mean depression and
all these things that are drugging us
that's right to run from are the things
that make us but if you are a
materialist if you are an atheist if you
believe that there is no spirit why are
you making that argument why not just
take the drug and make yourself happier
because it's incumbent on me to find
some happiness here why I think you have
to I think I could quote I think Larry
David took this originally from somebody
else but the end of anything go or
anything goes anything works one of his
movies a couple years ago wasn't even a
great movie I'm totally acting anything
works say not say anything something
with the word a there but at the end he
said your job on this earth is to pilfer
any bit of happiness and joy out of it
that you can I would
my belief is somewhere within that that
it's it's tough you got to do the best
you can to find some some great
connections hopefully find someone you
love
the life in a home that you love and put
some good out there and that I don't
think you need to believe in something
that you can't prove to to attain that
well I would just say all I would say to
your audience and and you know I
actually see your show and I see that
think you have an audience of really
good will which I read many people faith
to which I love yeah but you know I
would say to that is put into the what I
call the toddler test if you have a
toddler toddlers volume around like a
why why why just want you know punch
like that yeah when you say you know you
should find what happiness you can when
you say that you should be good to
people when you say it ask yourself why
because this is the question that really
uh if you don't know the answer to that
all the way down to the ground when they
come and tell you you know really you
should turn over your Jews you know like
it or will kill you you don't know why
you shouldn't why should you die why
should you go in why should a 20 year
old God
go and die to protect a constitution
that he's never going to live to enjoy
you know why should he do that if and
yet if people don't do that there are no
constitutions there are no free
countries oh and and yet and everybody
knows it everybody knows that like every
single person knows in his heart that
that is a noble act to die for someone
else and yet if there's no God if
there's no spirit
it's insane act and so all I'm saying
but you those principles could still be
there but without the without that leap
of faith you know those principles it's
there the principles can be there
without your believing but but you just
don't they're just not making sense what
you're saying is making sense you know I
once saw Bill Maher make offense I've
really done a good number well the thing
that you know you if you give you put
yourself through that toddler test you
will find that you run out of answers
and and I don't find that and and I
think you know you know the funny the
funny thing is is that for hundreds of
years for a couple hundred years after
Newton atheism made sense
atheism made sense Sully and typically
it's has stopped making sense and the
way you can tell that it stopped making
sense is there used to be something
called the God of the gaps that ever
this expression that I got out of the
gaps was when scientists couldn't
explain something the
the religious people go AHA yes God you
know to fill in the gaps oh I've got it
now there's science of the gaps the
world is created so exactly for for
human understanding what they call the
anthropic principle it's going to create
it so much so that we can understand it
that scientists have had to invent
multiple universes with no proof
whatsoever there's absolutely no proof
whatsoever of multiple universes they've
had to invent it simply to explain away
how things could be so exactly made for
our benefit it's just it's just an its
science of the gaps they made it up
because they can't explain it without a
creator for a long time atheism made
sense it has ceased to make sense and
the problem and things cease to make
sense is not that you become a bad
person it's that you become vulnerable
to attack you become vulnerable to
logical attack because you don't know
what you believe or why and that's
that's my argument yeah and I and I
think it's a great argument that I can
you know shred well here I don't nor is
that the intention of when I sit down
with some course because I want to hear
right what you think or you know one of
the things I intend on doing over the
next column much is doing more uh you
know debates not this cable news scream
debate but you know get you in here with
a guy like Lawrence Krauss who I had on
a few weeks goes and astrophysicist on
does operate often in that area of yeah
we don't know what you know I'm just out
there it's theoretics basically so we
should do some of these sit down and lay
some of that out because I fear you
would not be afraid of that about that
debate in any way no I say with him I
mean but in general I'm really afraid
I'm never afraid of the debate that is
actually a search for truth I worry
about debates in which people are just
trying to win yeah you know which that's
what almost all are divided overcome
people can I'm not interested in so
people can win and yet you know that
they're saying something illogical you
know and that's uh but I'm never I'm
never afraid to talk about things
because I think that's that's what it's
all about you know that is you know it
that's the other thing we know people
keep trying to tell us that we're who
were sleep with or what we eat what we
believe you know what we truly believe
and and I think that that's why the left
is always attacking us in the realm of
ideas but leaving us free in the realm
of the flesh you know and and I think
and the answer is not to do the
opposite of that I think people should
be as free in the realm of the flesh as
they can be without hurting me you know
not so free that they can set my house
on fire but you have to walk in and be
you they are you know but but most
importantly they should be free to see
the world as they see it this for
instance is where when when people say I
you know somebody says I'm a woman and
therefore you have to call me she and I
think no no wait a minute you know you
can say you whatever you want to say but
you can't tell me how to perceive the
word yeah but because that's it that's
infringing on who I truly am my ideas my
truth right I mean usually when I see a
woman I say she or whatever but now they
have all these other things and it's
like and that has become one of my main
issue with the progresses is that the
second they decide you have to change
and you have to accept their new edict
if you don't change the day that they
change now you're the bigot in the home
of us in the sexes and that's just that
to me is a place where you will spin off
into true chaos because who's going to
stop them from che what's next and
what's next what's next then what's neck
and while I'm preaching while I'm
preaching I read you religion yeah yeah
yeah and then they'll he'll miss you
walk again yeah but but what while I'm
preaching so much of that has to do with
shame you know in Christianity they have
this idea of original sin which offends
a lot of people but it simply means
you're not the person you know you
should be and there's a certain amount
of shame like even Freud had to explain
that he had to make Freud had to make up
a myth to explain this the myth of the
primal father we killed and now we all
feel guilty because I have to say why
why do people walk around feeling guilty
all the time the left wants to outlaw
that but because they think that they
they can just stop this guy from hating
you because you're transgender then
you'll feel great about it and center
no you won't once you realize that being
a human being comes along with a certain
mother shame and guilt you're free you
know nobody has a no it's an inside job
it's an attack it's an inside that is a
great um I'm curious and then and then
we'll wrap up here to this but what
about the the stuff that people would
say all right everything he said here it
sounded pretty pretty solid he has his
own set of principles that he's living
by all good but
about the the stuff in in the Bible in
the New Testament that you can't take
literally I mean do you take some of
that stuff literally that that well
here's where I would follow that here's
where I was get in trouble with with
Christian people I believe every word of
the Bible is true but but they're
different genres for telling the truth
if I come in the door and I say I there
was a burning building out there and I
ran and I saved two children that better
be literally physically historically
true if I say they're they the building
talk to you that would be that if I say
D once upon a time there were two
children who were lost in the woods you
don't say like where when did this
happen
what day was that you know there are
different drawings in in the Bible yeah
you know for a for instance the book of
the first books of Genesis I believe are
some may be the most profound writing
ever done by human babies so profound
such a perfect description that I don't
think they were trying to describe
something that they saw or something
that they knew for certain from most of
the church's history that was not taken
literal you know is not taken this is
exactly what happened it was taken as a
statement of cosmic truth which it is
it's a different genre than some of the
historical writing I think that that
doesn't mean that I don't believe in
miracles because I do and I've seen
something I think we've all seen them
actually more than we think you know I
do think that in order for Christianity
to be true the Gospels have to be the
place where history and metaphor come
together and I think that if and st.
Paul says this if the resurrection is
not true the whole thing is bogus that
is that's the point that says here's the
proof here's the proof and you know I
wasn't there I certainly think it's very
hard to argue there was no empty tomb I
don't think any historian can really
argue that there was no empty tomb
people went out and died they went into
Jerusalem and to where people were there
remember the people were there they saw
what happened and said the tomb is empty
Jesus was raised from the grave nobody
said well white let's just go over to
the tomb you know so there's evidence
that this is true but I think that
that's the place where the rubber meets
the road but there's lots of stuff in
the Bible that I take as legend and
because as a kind of writing that
conveys you simply can't convey every
level of truth with historical writing
you can't do it that's I'm a novelist as
I tell that aren't ready to tell me to
tell the truth yeah and I think that
there's a there is a lot of that about
yeah well that seems like a fitting
ending to me all right
buddy I think we didn't have to bludgeon
each other no but I can miss Bibles very
violent we didn't have to a lot of death
we didn't have to do any of that sex to
about a sex we're not going to do that
no no that we marry all right well it
really was a pleasure because you can
grab I'll do this again I thought we had
reached out to you like six months ago
but unless there's a ghost in the
machine that could really we never did
it
all right well for more on Andrew and
where to find his books and more of his
work check out Andrew Klavan dot-com and
the Andrew Klavan Joe is right here on
YouTube so just stick it in the Google
search thing right up above
you